what's happening reject nation it's Greg
Alva here
it's caelum in here Kiley man from the
fan Theory YouTube channel here today
we're gonna talk about tragedy girls you
guys haven't seen the trailer for
tragedy girls we sure did so we got
invited to the premiere thanks Caroline
for calling us
you rocked it we want to be here to give
her honest opinion today boy was that
crowd in an uproar that was a crowd was
really high I don't think I've been it's
been a while somebody where the violent
deaths occurred everyone's like it's
about these two teenagers in high school
who are running this social media like a
mainly their Twitter that they're
focused on they're building it up and
they want to get a bigger following so
they become these serial killers and
they start covering events of the deaths
and like who's the murderer and why are
these children going yeah they're
covering the mystery but they're the
ones responsible for it and this film is
like a slasher satire yeah and it's a
completely new take on that whole genre
because this time around it's like your
main characters are amazing yeah you're
not focused on the group of victims
you don't have a Sydney the main central
focus is the two girls and they kind of
just hop right into it the film is very
funny but it's super twisted it really
is when you hear dark comedy and I think
that's one comment I made when we were
watching the trailer was I really want
them to commit to the dark elements of
this they do they really commit to the
twisted nature of these two girls who
are young super detached sociopaths who
only care about increasing their
following and love killing people so you
do get a story about serial killers do
yeah and they do in such a weirdly
charismatic way that has like whimsical
you you appreciate them and you like
them but you're also like I really don't
really hate because the movie has this
interesting effect that I really respect
because they're doing it based off
serial killers and they don't take like
the Dexter path they're only killing bad
people like no they're killing like
good-hearted innocent people and so the
film has this interesting contrast of I
like these guys they're good they're
good
they're fun characters and then when
they kill people you're like I hate
these guys hate them so much that's to
the film's credit though that's what the
effect of the film I think they want you
to feel yeah I think it's the in-between
in the relationship between the two
girls that makes you really love them
the most yes they have such a true
friendship it's hard not to love these
characters and love each other and yeah
the weird twist to the way the weird
theme of it is friendship yeah that's
what I mean by satire cuz it's a
high-school story about two girls
wanting to do something if you take out
killing and replace it with something
else it's it's a high school movie yeah
about girls is wanting to have a future
they have their conflicts but they also
have this bond that's unbreakable and
everything has a hashtag associated and
there's some great social media
commentary
especially after what we do there are
some jokes that especially early on Rome
like what the average person really care
about this if they're not really heavily
involved but my following will grow
Alexander and Alexander ship and
Hildebrand yeah granda hell the brown
was negasonic teenage warhead storm and
expand apocalypse Breanna is is great in
the movie there my god so both great
they're fantastic actually in this film
Alexandra Shipp she was the best she was
so good she was like my favorite yeah
she was she was the one where in a film
that is this whimsical kind of detached
from reality I think I'm the thing I
told you in the car was it felt like
this great the writing approach was
looking at social media personalities
and then going how would they behave in
real life because these personalities
some of them are kind of like a satire
of social media personality yeah but
Alexandra Shipp though she gets the
points in this film where you're like
she's genuinely scary actually really
scary she's yeah wanna entertain she's
committed she's really emotional but
there are times we were like she's kind
of terrifying yeah it's so incredibly
sweet and her actions and how she speaks
and then she just does these things
without any soul attack yeah complete
detachment from the fact that she's
doing what she's doing and yeah
and I feel like that's what the
commentaries on in terms of yesl media
like it's a really big emotional
detachment because that's another aspect
I like to it is how these two girls when
they're doing their killing they're just
talking like teenage girls totally
normal thing and we're going to like
bloodless yeah I'm a creepy killer they
never go into that they just remain
teenage girls which is I think part of
the reason why you still like them
because it's like okay well yeah sweet
girls they just happen to be because
it's eerie and uncomfortable their
tongues are laughing or you're like I'm
laughing but I can feel kind of weird
I'm really terrible yeah that's what
makes her a great kind of twisted
slasher movie in my opinion this doesn't
follow traditional format of beech
sheets of slasher film in high school
because you're focused on these two
girls behave just like regular teenage
girls yeah it's just the actions they do
are very different
by being murderer yeah satisfying
because of some of what they do in the
movie and how they respond to each other
how they take care of certain things
yeah it's really incredibly entertaining
to watch at the same time there's a few
moments where you're just like oh man
why man what to the film's major credit
it starts off interesting it
progressively gets more engaging yeah
film keeps going yeah and I like that
because at first I was like this is
interesting but I'm not fully pulled in
but as the film keeps going about like
30 minutes in I'm like okay I'm now I'm
pulled in yeah and then oh I'm even
pulled in more now okay so yeah it's a
good build of situations there's a whole
cast in here that is fantastic not
everyone in here gets a lot of screen
time there's a lot of supporting
characters yeah movie I find that the
casting was great and the character
writing of them was really good Josh
Hutcherson oh he's so funny in this so
fun so fun please the douchiest dude
ever yeah and he's barely in it but he's
really good kevin durand was actually
one of my favorite actors in this movie
a lot of people don't recognize
other than from like the strain or
whatever but he was so good I can't tell
you much without saying he plays creepy
psychotic he plays yeah yeah Craig
Robinson and he produced the film - yeah
he has a pretty pivotal role in the
movie and he's really good in it too and
whenever they show up it's like
sometimes these characters get
introduced a little later and they're
there it's worth having them there oh
yeah the likeable dude who's in love
with negasonic teenage warhead Jack
Quaid this movie has a lot of
performances that are intentionally a
bit surreal a little detached from
reality Jack Quaid is the one one of the
few characters in this film who's very
sincere probably the more relatable one
it's hard not to like him really hard
not to like him yeah really there's
nothing wrong with him yeah he's
probably the main dude the main guy I'm
still because his character I don't
really feel like he's giving anything
away they're building up their social
media building up to their video posts
and he's thought he's the guy who helps
them out but he has no idea what they
who they really are he doesn't he's not
aware that they're actually killers but
he has a crush on Brianna and he his
performance is the one where you're like
Cathy V Murphy as the sheriff character
in this film yeah who plays his father
he's really good he's kind of like the
Rick from Walking Dead for this the
actor Keith Hudson he plays the dad of
Brianna and they live in like a trailer
park kind of home but he has some of the
funniest lines some of the funniest
moments when you're not expecting him to
be funny but he's so hilarious so this
film really commits to the being funny
it commits to the weirdness it commits
to like there's a few gory moments too
we're like whoa it's not as gory as some
people might lead you to believe it is
yeah no I was actually pleasantly
surprised with how oh yeah cuz I'm not a
huge Gore guy but this was like a
perfect balance I think it wasn't
overkill at times kind of whimsical yeah
sometimes there are times where you're
like that's kind of there are other
times where this is just kind of
whimsical I think the film is very
enjoyable overall I think it's a pretty
solid piece of material and it's
definitely
original it goes against the grain and
it challenges the audience on liking the
main carriage though is a perfect word
for me yes it's definitely that yeah
wouldn't because that first I was like
oh it's kind of like a Heather's meat
scream and then after a while you're
like not just something are issues with
the film only come in with the finale
but we can't go into that because I
would spoil the movie for you guys but
that's only a small portion of the film
as compared to like 90 to 95 percent of
the movie yeah I mean I definitely would
say I more than liked the movie
yeah I'm more than yeah yeah it's hard
for me to say I love this movie yeah and
in an intellectual way I love the movie
yeah cause it really messes with you
yeah so much you're so confused on how
you should feel after leaving that movie
and that's why intellectually I love it
yeah emotionally I think it's really
good great but my heart doesn't feel
like I love it but my mind is like I
love it so many great moments in that
movie that it's like for me it's like
yeah you should see it but I kind of
have to be prepared to feel a little
yeah that's good cuz it really commits
to the twist in this and the dark mom oh
it definitely is this is a definition of
a horror dark comedy yeah cuz there are
some moments that are pretty intense
there's a couple moments where I saw you
pretty much I would say I would give it
like if there was a star rating I'll
probably give it like four out of five
stars actually if I were to rate this
movie yeah I wouldn't give it a good
four stars
yes solid forward yeah yeah go watch the
movie I mean it's getting like a limited
release and LA in New York this Friday
and then it should probably be like
nationwide October 27th there's a lot of
social media buzz over this film has
been playing a lot of screenings and I
was ultimately more pleasantly surprised
than what I was expecting to be yeah
yeah I know you're a little hesitant
with it I was and yeah and what time I
was under like really good and the crowd
was the crowd was really in a no we were
a scream fest when we saw it yeah and
that's like all horror movies horror
movie crowds can be a little bit like a
Binyam horror movie crowds before work
you know they can be like Nick
and judging criticizing but they were
having a rollicking good oh yeah now
yeah absolutely it's one hell of an
entertaining film alright guys well
that's our review of tragedy girls I
hope you guys get a chance to go watch
it it's one hell of an entertaining
twisted film that's for sure let me ask
you guys what is your favorite slasher
movie of all time put it in the comments
below engagement you can subscribe to
the Rio rejects click that notification
bell follow Kyle element on his youtube
channel fan theory right here you could
click it orders the card that appeared
or there's a link in the description
boxes follow him follow - you saw the
regular on this channel man he needs
your support so following and check out
our patreon if you want do it guys it's
worth it I got some good stuff we've got
some good stuff